the kansas city royals it's going to be
right-handed jacob junis making his
third start of the season he has gone a
total of 10 innings giving up just two
earned runs to go along with 12
strikeouts junis fighting his command
here in the first inning problem is
jacob junis has not been able to find
the plate and he has missed badly with
his first three offerings here tonight
and another one wide and all four
pitches plenty wide of the strike zone
and the rays immediately get a base
runner and four pitches
banning second as the d8 ground ball
down to first down to second
one and back to first not in time
a nice hustle by yoshi getting up that
first base line and preventing the
royals from turning the double play
so one on one out for joey wendell
wendell
has been the slugger in this lineup
lifted in the air to right center field
on the run is michael a taylor he can't
get it it's an rbi double by joey
wendell and the rays take a one-nothing
lead here in the first inning brandon
lau at the plate here's a swing and a
high fly ball right field isbell going
back turns around splashdown
he sends it into the fountains
and the rays take a three-nothing first
inning lead jacob junis had given up
just two runs in 12 innings coming in
without a homer allowed yandi's been in
a little bit of a [ __ ] his average down
to 264.
3-2 pitch is inside ball four a couple
of close pitches
did not go jonas's way and he walks his
second batter this inning after having
only three walks coming into the game so
here is kevin kiermeier and now this one
low and gets by perez and that will
allow yandy diaz to move into scoring
position
again ugly in the field pitch down perez
goes down and it slips through the five
hole let's see if kk could put the ball
in play in the pitch if swung on it
popped up shallow left field ben and
tendy coming in now will hit the brakes
and make the catch back to second goes
diaz and there's two outs diaz at second
francisco mejia will have an opportunity
to add to the ray's early lead that's a
shot going to be fair hit the ball hard
past santana
diaz heads to the plate and the rays
tack on another run well the abdomen is
hitting in the number eight spot here's
the swing and a live drive and this one
is caught by the shortstop nikki lopez
michael walker's got a four-nothing lead
as he takes to the mound on the bottom
of the first wit mirrorfield hitting
over 300 himself swinging a ground ball
sharply hit but right to the second
baseman brandon loud the right of second
throws to first and yandi dropped it but
then picked it up
just in time
to get the out at first base well
there's carlos santana there's a
sky-high pop-up into that wind fowl
territory diaz dancing with it and then
he runs over brandon lau to make the
catch all right do gone in that case if
if you're allowed you want to be careful
yes because that's a pretty good size
defender there at first base and diaz
gloves it with that mitt two outs four
nothing raised here's salvador perez
and the pitch to him is grounded sharply
right to shore handled by willie adonis
his throw is offline
yandi comes off the bag and tags out
salvador perez and so
three outs recorded quickly by waka the
royals have their first space runner
that brings up hunter dozier dozier
cranks it to deep left field and that is
gone and the royals are on the board
with hunter dozier's first home run of
the year and it's 4-2 in the second
inning michael walker will face celery
he'll pump one out of the yard here real
soon you watch him he's been really
looking a lot more on time here we go
hud good call
you said it was coming soon and that's
up onto the steps you're the royals hall
of fame and that swing has really
leveled out the last two games and now
the royals are down by one in the fourth
inning runners at second and third and
one out the infield comes in for joey
wendell red-hot power hitter that's
lifted into left and ben and tindy will
go back
and make the catch in a more
conventional style to play that baseball
and meadows will tag
and score and the rays will pick up
run number five of the evening on a
sacrifice fly wendell's second run bad
at end of the night an interesting
inning coming up from michael walka
santana perez and solaire protecting a
two-run lead but remember the bullpen is
a little short tonight and there's
nobody warming swing and a drive
to deep right center field phillips
going back warning track to the wall
jumps up and makes the catch up against
the out of town scoreboard for out
number one he was a step or so away from
the wall
and went up to make the leaping catch
salvi he is over two one of his outs was
a line out to phillips well hit right
field phillips gets turned around twice
and it stays in by inches
salvi thinks it's a home run and he's
going to be out
oh man the royals will take another look
at it but no umpire made any kind of
home run
ruling the only umpire that reacted to
it was the second base umpire roberto
ortiz with his arms out at his sides to
say no
it stayed in
wow man you know what i was just about
to say catch this one
oh
kicked right back in too bad man another
inch from
salvi's angle he thought it hit the
railing right behind there
just
going into his home run trot yeah he was
so no home run salvi is out
[Music]
dozier is due up waka responsible for a
man at second and springs the
left-hander comes on oh one pitch
grounded to the left side diving stop
there by wendell he does everything
throws the first in time
and that will retire the side joey
wendell he's the big bopper at the plate
and he's a gold glover around the
diamond
lead off man aboard in the top of the
order austin meadows 3-2
and that's a shot up the right side is
it fair that's a fair ball off the wall
comes back to isabelle who bobbles it
phillips turning the corner on this and
he will score ahead of the throw
and the rings pick up an additional run
joey wendell coming up foul tip did he
hang on
how about that
in his glove
out of his glove but salvi was able to
recover before it hit the dirt so the
rays looking at a concerning situation
here and into your hit and now the walk
two minute on with nobody out here in
the bottom of the seventh inning and now
hanzo alberta will be the batter
right center field phillips is on the
run and it's going to sail over his head
then attendees around third taylor's
around third alberto is into third with
a triple and it's a one-run game in the
seventh and a hitter who's been knocking
the cover off the ball carlos santana at
the plate belts it to right
deep
and
gone
the royals down four nothing at one
point in this game have roared all the
way back 90 feet away from tying this
game is randy a rosarina going to pinch
hit swing the ground ball towards finish
through
into left field for a base hit the rays
have an answer it is seven to seven the
race put the lead off man aboard joey
wendell will be the hitter runner goes
the pitch swing and a slicer down the
left field nine it's fahren rolls all
the way toward the corner it's another
rbi double by joey wendell he does it
again and he gives the raise an eight to
seven lead diego castillo is brought on
to try to get the last three outs the
time run is a third nikki lopez up there
and they do a little safety squeeze and
the game is tied
the royals playing a little small ball
dyson coming in like a bullet
ray's walk the royal who's had the best
home stand to pitch to the guy who's had
the second best home stand salvador
perez
base hit
what a home stand for salvador perez
or the royals just would not go away
tonight